et aux premières auditions du procès
j'ai trouvé vraiment que le monde
finalement été formés de gens
merveilleux et d'aidé de jean ignoble en
fait vous ne savez pas comment votre
fils est mort vous devez enquêter sur
tout et vous confronter ils étaient ni
sur la liste des morts n'est sûr y ait
des blessés ni shalit et hopitalisé il
était nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane et en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
bégu des pourparlers ce soir à genève
entre les états unis et la russie une
semaine de discussions consacrées à la
crise ukrainienne et à la sécurité en
europe la russie a exclu toute
concession moscou qui se dit déçu par
les signaux envoyés profiter
[Musique]
le calme semble être revenu mais la
tension reste vive au kazakhstan le pays
secoué cette semaine par de violentes
émeutes contre la hausse du prix du gaz
sont fait des dizaines de morts et plus
d'un millier de blessés et sur demande
du gouvernement kazakh l'organisation
régionale au tst à déployer une force de
maintien de la paix
c'est parti la russe
[Musique]
le projet de loi instituant le pass
vaccinale arrive au sénat le texte sera
examiné en commission des lois demain
après midi avant d'être discuté dans
l'hémicycle à partir de mardi texte
adopté par l'assemblée nationale après
trois jours et une nuit de débats agités
le gouvernement espère une entrée en
vigueur au plus tard la semaine 17
janvier
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous soyez les bienvenus si
vous nous rejoignez sur rt france
le début d'une semaine à fort enjeu
diplomatique
les pourparlers américano russes s'ouvre
ce soir avec un premier échange avant la
principale réunion demain alors que
moscou est accusé d'avoir amassé 100
mille militaires à la frontière
ukrainienne la russie et les etats unis
se retrouvent à genève il sera question
de la sécurité en europe viendront
ensuite une réunion otan russie mercredi
à bruxelles puis une rencontre jeudi à
vienne de l'organisation pour la
sécurité et la coopération en europe
avec donc les européens en direct de
suisse on retrouve tout de suite notre
reporter guimard aussi
bons sentiments c'est par un face à face
des vice ministres des affaires
étrangères des états unis et de la
russie que devrait démarrer les
discussions elles n'ont pas encore
commencé mais les déclarations ont déjà
formulé de part et d'autre laisse
présager des négociations houleuses
et oui tout à fait un saut fillon
connaît déjà plus ou moins les positions
des uns et des autres et elles sont loin
d'augurer des négociations apaisées
c'est d'autant plus dommage que
l'objectif premier de cette rencontre
entre wendy sherman et sergei ryabkov
les numéros deux des diplomaties
américaine et russe et de cet objectif
premier n'a en réalité pas grand chose à
voir initialement avec le dossier le
dossier ukrainien il s'agit au départ
plutôt de discussions sur le désarmement
nucléaire ou sur l' équilibre entre les
deux puissances atomiques alors sherman
et riabkov se sont rencontrées deux fois
cette année à genève pour discuter de la
stabilité stratégique et ce devait être
à nouveau le cas demain le début de ces
négociations sauf que depuis bien la
crise ukrainienne a totalement
phagocyter l'ordre du jour de ces
discussions cela fait des mois et des
mois que washington et moscou sont à
couteaux tirés sur ce dossier et
malheureusement pour le moment
apparemment personne ne semble disposé à
céder le moindre pouce de terrain à
commencer par les états unis qui jugent
inacceptables les demandes de moscou
écouter
la russie exige maintenant que les états
unis et l'otan signe des traités pour
retirer les forces de l'otan stationnés
sur le territoire des alliés en europe
centrale et orientale et pour interdire
à l'ukraine d'adhérer un jour à l'otan
ils veulent nous entraîner dans un débat
sur l'otan plutôt que de se concentrer
sur la question qui nous occupe à savoir
leur agression contre l'ukraine
alors le secrétaire général de l'otan
jens stoltenberg a d'ailleurs lui aussi
fait une déclaration en ce sens et du
côté de moscou est bien le ton est à peu
près le même aucune concession a déclaré
le vice ministre ryabkov temps que les
demandes russes n'ont pas été acceptées
malheureusement nous entendons toutes
sortes de spéculations la russie devrait
faire cela devrait faire autre chose
certes elle pas telle autre pas nous
avons réagi à maintes reprise à une
telle formulation de la question à tous
les niveaux il ne peut ici avoir de base
ni pour un accord ni même pour une
discussion productive
saga ryabkov a même déclaré que la
délégation russe ne discuterait pas des
mesures de désescalade demandées par
washington et l'otan à la frontière
ukrainienne alors comme ça c'est clair
donc tout n'est pas perdu cependant
washington et moscou ont tous deux
exprimé leur intérêt de discuter de
l'emplacement de certains dispositifs
domicile par exemple ou encore de
l'ampleur de certains exercices
militaires conduits par l'un ou par
l'autre des deux pays mais le ton des
négociations qui vont s'ouvrir dès
demain matin est clair et vous l'avez
dit elle ont déjà débuté en réalité ces
négociations avec un dîner de travail
dès ce soir entre ryabkov et shearman en
reste à espérer que cette entrevue
déboucha réellement sur des discussions
constructives merci beaucoup guy marrot
six ans directeur de genève
un retour au calme précaire au
kazakhstan au terme d'une semaine de
violentes émeutes débuté en provence
dimanche dernier après l'augmentation
des prix du gaz la contestation a gagné
les grandes villes comme allemagne est
de loin la plus touchée les émeutes qui
ont fait des dizaines de morts et plus
d'un millier de blessés retour sur les
faits avec françoise et les lambert
c'est une marée humaine qui déferle dans
les rues de plusieurs villes du
kazakhstan dimanche dernier des milliers
de personnes font entendre leur colère
au gouvernement le pouvoir vient de
doubler les prix du gaz auparavant
plafonné depuis le début de l'année ces
derniers sont passés de 60 à 120 gay la
monnaie locale le temps est venu de
s'unir de se rassembler allons-y les
kazakhes face à la colère des
manifestants
le pouvoir tente dans un premier temps
de se justifier avant de faire une
concession les autorités fixe à 55 et le
litre de gas naturel liquéfié dans les
régions du sud ouest du pays où la
contestation est la plus vive mais la
mesure ne calme pas les protestataires
le mouvement s'étend à almaty capitale
économique et plus grande ville du pays
dans la nuit de mardi à mercredi des
milliers de manifestants prennent
d'assaut le siège de l'administration
locale
je veux aussi convives tous bien au
kazakhstan vous voyez que tout est
devenu plus cher l'essence le gaz les
produits alimentaires tout est devenu
plus cher nous ne voulons pas de ça
c'est le chaos c'est vraiment le chaos
alors que les affrontements se font de
plus en plus violents le président
kazakh prend des mesures drastiques
kassim jomart tokayev décrète l'état
d'urgence la mise en place d'un
couvre-feu et limoge son gouvernement
malgré ces annonces les manifestants
continuent de défier la police kazakh
selon les autorités des dizaines de
personnes sont tuées et plus d'un
millier blessées
dans une nouvelle allocution le
président tokayev dénonce des actions
menées par des terroristes entraînés à
l'étranger le dirigeant kazakh menace
dans la foulée ce qu'ils continueront de
manifester
j'ai ordonné aux forces de l'ordre et à
l'armée d'ouvrir le feu pour tuer sans
sommation
le président kazakh lance également un
appel à l'aide aux pays membres de
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective
une demande acceptée par moscou qui
annonce l'envoi de ces troupes aux côtés
de contingents arménien biélorusse
tadjike kirghize une mission destinée à
maintenir la paix selon l'hôte et sc la
mission principale des forces
collectives de maintien de la paix de
l'hôtesse et sera d'assurer la
protection des sites étatique et
militaire important est d'aider les
forces de l'ordre de la république du
kazakhstan à stabiliser la situation et
à assurer le retour de cette dernière
dans le cadre légal
depuis bordeaux dit le calme est en
partie revenu dans les rues du
kazakhstan déserté mais le pouvoir
continue d'être sur ses gardes l'ex chef
des services de renseignements a été
placé en détention pour haute trahison
et sur demande du gouvernement kazakh et
dans le cadre d'une mission de maintien
de la paix déployés par l'organisation
du traité de sécurité collective la
russie notamment à déployer des soldats
dans le pays envoyé spécial pour rt
international amour à bhl de gaz jeff
est allé à la rencontre de ses unités
spéciales
chaque jour ici est considérablement
plus chargé que le précédent des
centaines de nouveaux soldats de la paix
arrive au kazakhstan tous les jours ses
troupes les forces de maintien de la
paix ont sécurisé d infrastructure
stratégique vital comme les centrales
électriques les bureaux gouvernementaux
les bases militaires et cetera ce qui
permet aux troupes casaque de rétablir
l'ordre dans les zones ciblées par les
émeutes les pillages et autres maraude
au total il y a eu 30 vols hier 50 vols
sont prévus aujourd'hui et l'activité ne
cesse de s'intensifier fft plateforme
jasta des années d'activité
[Musique]
et il ne s'agit pas seulement de soldats
de la paix russes tous les états membres
de l'hôtesse et ont répondu à l'appel à
l'aide du kazakhstan biélorussie
tadjikistan au kirghizistan et arménie
voici des troupes arméniennes récemment
arrivés d'autres soldats de la paix
venus apporter leur soutien au
kazakhstan cette unité d'une centaine de
personnes a répondu à l'appel du
gouvernement kazakh adressé à tous les
membres de l'organisation du traité de
sécurité collective
leur mission sera la même que celle des
autres soldats de la paix surveillez
diversit et permettre aux troupes
casaque de s'occuper du maintien de
l'ordre ce qui est absolument nécessaire
en ce moment environ 4000 personnes
émeutiers maraudeur suspects ont déjà
été arrêtés par la police et par l'armée
kazakh ils font maintenant face à de
lourdes peines qui peuvent aller jusqu'à
l'emprisonnement à perpétuité
des émeutes des incendies criminels des
vols et des agressions ont paralysé la
ville d'almaty les civils sont priés de
rester chez eux à l'écart des fenêtres
tandis que les forces kazakh
rétablissent l'ordre et arrêtent les
bandits et les terroristes comme il
appelle les pillards armés même
l'aéroport n'est pas entièrement
sécurisé c'est pourquoi de nombreuses
actions sont toujours en cours
les conditions de sécurité à almaty près
de l'aéroport sont toujours précaire les
troupes qui arrivent chaque jour sont
formés et s'entraînent régulièrement
pour empêcher l'infiltration par des
bandes armées ou par la foule qui s'est
parfois emparés d'armes dans divers
arsenaux militaires
elle s'efforce également de trouver les
éventuels infiltrés et de les arrêter
la présence des forces de l'ôter assez
au kazakhstan est temporaire certains
disent qu'il suffira d'un mois d'autres
2 mais il est trop tôt pour parler du
retrait immédiat des forces il y a tant
de choses à faire
la vie d'un soldat de la paix n'est pas
facile surtout les premiers jours les
innombrables patrouille le manque de
fournitures la quantité folle de travail
à accomplir et les nombreuses positions
à sécuriser
mais à l'heure actuelle l'ordre revient
peu à peu almaty et on espère que les
troubles qui ont secoué le pays seront
bientôt oublié
une crise qui a eu des répercussions sur
les cours de match de plusieurs matières
premières stratégiques le sous-sol
kazakh en regorge notamment d'uranium
le kazakhstan est le premier producteur
mondial juliette la miche
le kazakhstan est le plus grand
producteur de pétrole d'asie centrale
est le deuxième producteur des pays
partenaires de l'opep l'organisation des
pays exportateurs de pétrole en 2020 le
pays produisait près de 1,8 million de
barils par jour et selon la banque
mondiale le pétrole représentait 21 % de
son produit intérieur brut en seulement
une semaine de forte contestation au
kazakhstan les cours du pétrole ont
gagné près de 5% un contexte qui
pourrait avoir des répercussions
mondiales selon certains spécialistes
les émeutes représente clairement un
risque pour l'approvisionnement du
marché mondial
selon carsten fritsch analyste chez
commerzbank
le brent utilisé comme référence pour
déterminer le prix du pétrole brut a
dépassé ce vendredi son niveau le plus
haut depuis la chute des prix
consécutive à l'apparition du variant
omicron le kazakhstan génère près de 40%
de la production mondiale d'uranium et
fournit notamment les centrales
atomiques françaises pour l'heure le
marché ne semble pas impacté par la
crise déclenchée il ya près d'une
semaine dans le cas contraire la chine
pourrait être particulièrement concerné
plus de la moitié des exportations du
radium kazakh sont destinés à la chine
il pourrait y avoir des obstacles
logistiques et la livraison des produits
aux frontières car les principaux
itinéraires passe par la région d'almaty
où tous les principaux affrontements ont
eu lieu d'après des spécialistes la
chine dispose d'un stock d'uranium
suffisant pour répondre à ses besoins
dans un futur proche toujours selon les
experts la contestation kazakh pourrait
davantage créer un inconfort mineurs
plutôt qu'une crise majeure
et le kazakhstan représente un enjeu
pour les pays voisins et pour les
entreprises étrangères présentes dans le
pays c'est ce que nous explique et bruno
audrey fkih spécialiste de l'europe de
l'est historien fait maître de
conférences à l'inalco le kazakhstan on
vient de le voir regorge de richesses à
la fois donc pétrole l'uranium est par
ailleurs adopté et en liaison avec sa
beaucoup de compagnies étrangères
occidentales ou chinoises sont présents
dans le pays donc elles ont évidemment
vous intérêt direct dans ce pays et à
l'évolution de ce pays est important
pour elle et pour les pays qui sont
discrets les pays occidentaux et la
chine donc ça c'est un aspect le
deuxième aspect c'est que là le
kazakhstan n'occupe aucune place
stratégique sur les voies reliant la
chine l'asie orientale plus largement et
l'europe mais aussi
d'asie orientale et l'europe et l'asie
occidentale c'est à dire en fait tout ce
qu'on appelle les nouvelles routes de la
soie donc tout ça fait du du kazakhstan
un lieu de
lui stratégiques ont bien sûr
l'évolution du pays
ne peut pas laisser indifférent ce qui
explique évidemment si pourquoi les
relations les réactions internationales
sont parfois un peu mesuré et hésitant
en france le projet de loi instituant le
pass vaccinale sera entre les mains des
sénateurs à partir de demain qui
extraient examiné en commission des lois
dans l'après midi avant d'être discuté
dans l'hémicycle à partir de mardi texte
adopté par les députés cette semaine au
terme de trois jours de débats très
agités la majorité sénatoriale de droite
ça certes affiché son intention de voter
le texte mais elle l'a compte bien y
apporter des modifications
le gouvernement de son côté souhaite que
la mesure soit effective au plus tard
dans la semaine du 17 janvier pour
accéder aux activités de loisirs
restaurants ou encore robert un test
négatif ne suffira alors plus les plus
de 12 ans devront justifier d'un statut
vaccinal impasse vaccinale qui
remobilise contre lui plus de cent mille
protestataires ont manifesté hier
partout en france mobilisation quelques
jours après les propos d' emmanuel
macron qui ont interpellé le chef de
l'état assume en vouloir emmerder selon
ses mots les non-vaccinés
manifestations notamment à lyon marqué
par un incident un tir de grenade
lacrymogène lancée par la police a
atterri dans un appartement sans faire
de victime regardez
[Musique]
moi pas
m
je fais siffler mois
[Musique]
vergari
maintien
elle
[Musique]
je
mais
rien d'en parler
impasse vaccinale et restrictions
sanitaires qui ont fait descendre dans
les rues de bruxelles ce dimanche
quelques 5000 contestataires selon la
police les manifestants ont défilé entre
la gare de bruxelles-nord jusqu'au
quartier européen à l'appel du mouvement
ensemble pour la liberté il rassemble
plusieurs associations
les rassemblements sont récurrents dans
la capitale belge depuis plusieurs
semaines maintenant le certificat
sanitaire est exigée dans le pays pour
accéder aux restaurants et aux
événements culturels notamment le
ministre belge de la santé s'est
prononcée dans la journée en faveur de
l'organisation d'un débat au parlement
fédéral aussi vite que possible sur
l'obligation vaccinale ou l'instauration
d'un passé l'ex inhalent comme en france
achètent pas d'accord de tout ce qui se
passe c'est pas bien gros 23 à la
catastrophe là je pense qu'il faut
sortir quoi est dans la rue et dire non
on n'avait pas tout ça c'est une des
surprises complètement absurde
qui atteint aux libertés énormément
c'est pas un vaccin ou pas vaccin c'est
le choix des gens et la liberté argent
et qu en gestion christian pour but la
santé et pas les intérêts financiers ou
politiques 1
en allemagne face à la propagation du
variant mikron et à la montée des
infections les autorités décident de
restreindre à davantage l'accès au café
ou au restaurant
à compter du 15 janvier pour s'y rendre
les clients devront présenter un test
négatif en plus d'un certificat de
vaccination ou de guérison du coc vides
seules les personnes ayant déjà reçu une
dose de rappel seront exemptés de test
pour les non vaccinés les commerces non
essentiel ainsi que les lieux de loisirs
et de culture leur reste interdite même
s'ils ont été diagnostiqués négatif
après un test des mesures qui ont
entraîné des manifestations hier à
düsseldorf notamment
je suis mère de quatre enfants c'est
pour ça que je suis ici aujourd'hui pour
m'assurer utiliser un avenir digne
d'être vécue et apprécié
je suis choqué que les enfants doivent
porter des masques tous les jours de
voir respirer le même air encore et
encore parfois ils sont harcelés
je souhaite que toutes les personnes de
ce pays qui aimerait avoir un avenir
digne d'être vécue se dresse contre
toutes les formes de discrimination
bonjour je m'appelle ralph je suis dans
la rue depuis 21 mois et j 3 vaccins
je suis ici parce que nous sommes
ensemble comme une seule famille humaine
et parce que nous ne voulons pas
supporté cette vaccination obligatoire
là des sanctions qualifié de très dur à
l'encontre de la junte militaire au mali
sanctions adopté dans la journée par la
cedeao foufs les dirigeants ouest
africains étaient réunis à accra au
ghana ils ont notamment décidé de fermer
les frontières avec le mali est de
mettre le pays sous embargo
les autorités maliennes se voit
reprocher le non respect de l'échéance
de février pour des élections ramenant
les civils au pouvoir décryptage de
notre grand reporter rt france régis le
sommier il est en direct avec man
bonsoir régissent la cedeao a également
décidé de couper les aides financières
et de geler les avoirs du mali à la
banque centrale des états de l'afrique
de l'ouest des sanctions plus
rigoureuses encore que celle adoptée
après le premier putsch d'août 2020
will est clairement il ya une volonté
justement de comment d'isoler le mali
est donc la junte militaire au pouvoir
pour la forcer essayez de la contraindre
justement à la tenue de ces élections
alors c'est un c'est nouveau les sextoys
hall ou de vous l'avez rappelé mais la
fermeture des frontières la fermeture
des espaces aériens là la fin des
transactions financières et surtout la
fin de l'aide financière au mavi octroyé
par la cedeao qui permet au pays
justement de de commandes de lutter
aussi contre
tous les mouvements de déstabilisation
qui qui agitent le mali en ce moment
donc il faut quand même rappeler aussi
que tout n'est pas non plus tout n'est
pas non plus fermé puisque les produits
de première nécessité pourront continuer
à circuler également les produits
pharmaceutiques
notamment tout ce qui concerne la crise
du coc vide est également tout ce qui
est comment de pétrole électricité donc
on n ya pas une une fermeture totale du
mali avec ses pays voisins mais il
s'agit quand même de ces de sanctions
très dures qui interviennent à un moment
où le mali est en plein doute ça
intervient aussi dans le moment où la
france a décidé de de quitter la région
du nord du mali pour que se concentrer
vers la zone des trois frontières donc
barkan probablement va comme on va
s'interrompre aulas dans les mois qui
viennent il ya encore des troupes
françaises qui sont là et donc il ya eu
une forme de come ans d'atermoiements et
déstabilisation en ce moment au mali la
situation sécuritaire notamment dans le
nord et dans le centre du pays est
compliqué et il y a aussi surtout c'est
surtout ça en toile de fond aussi les
accords qui ont comme en ukraine qui
aurait été conclu même si le
gouvernement malien déni comment leur
existence avec la société militaire
privée wagner là plusieurs sources la
semaine dernière ont d'ailleurs rapporté
que des véhicules circulant dans la
halle au sud de la ville de mopti donc
aux eaux comment au centre du pays d'
entre les deux villages de bandiagara et
donc casse est une zone contrôlée par la
katiba masinac est un des des groupes
djihadistes les plus actifs aux manies
et bien des incidents auraient conduit
au finalement et blessé un des
mercenaires de wagner effet les morts du
côté des soldats maliens et du côté des
djihadistes donc premier voilà ce qu ont
esquissé ce s'est passé la semaine
dernière un premier incident entre
wagner les forces maliennes et des
groupes jihadistes dans le centre du
mali donc c'est donc une situation
extrêmement tendue il faut aussi mais il
faut bien regarder que mali aujourd'hui
est un pays qu'on peut qualifier inde et
a failli dans lequel les groupes
jihadistes
comment circulent comme ils veulent
parce que les autorités n'ont toujours
pas réussi à reprendre des pans entiers
du pays les services publics ne sont pas
assurés dans sainte anne un certain
nombre de municipalités et la présence
même de l'armée parfois est très
aléatoire donc il ya très peu de
contrôles et le mali a besoin de pouvoir
contrôler son territoire donc ce n'est
pas évidemment avec le recul le retrait
de barkan et des français plus cet axe
asphyxie financière ou en tout cas cette
mise à l'index de la part des voisins
que le mali jusque va pouvoir s'en
sortir dans ces conditions alors est-ce
que ça servira à infléchir la junte
militaire et un précipité le retour d'un
pouvoir civil vous avez que ceux des
accords qui ont été signés le président
assimile bouaita et son premier ministre
choguel maïga se sont engagés à tenir
ces élections un prétexte de leur côté
que la situation sécuritaire ne permet
pas de tenir ses élections et qu' il est
illusoire de vouloir les qu'elle ait
lieu à la date du 27 février il demande
plus de temps la communauté
internationale la cedeao considère qu'
il s'agit pour la junte militaire au
pouvoir d'une manière de repousser
l'échéance est de conserver ce même
pouvoir et la gente militaire à mayenne
juge également nécessaire des réformes
préalables pour que les élections ne
souffre pas de nouvelles contestations
est ce que c'est un argument recevable
selon régis
écouter la question est de pouvoir que
toutes les parties au mali puisse se
présenter à ces élections et que lille
il y ait un climat suffisamment sorin je
pense que la donne sécuritaire et plus
un argument recevable que la question de
la représentativité ou en tout cas des
divers partis comme ces brandie par la
junte je pense que la question la
question sécuritaire c'est pouvoir tout
simplement amener des observateurs pour
prouver que les élections auront lieu et
puis surtout pouvoir amener lésions dans
des zones qui aujourd'hui échappent au
contrôle de l'armée malienne au et au
pouvoir central merci beaucoup pour
votre décryptage régis le sommier grand
reporter rt france
lft ruf nous avoir suivis c'est la fin
de cette édition se retrouve à 21h pour
un nouveau journal à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
m je pensais que tout le monde
connaissait déjà kim philby le plus
fameux des espions britanniques après
james bond rappelez-nous pourquoi elle
s'est tournée vers le communisme il
pensait que la gauche s'étaient vendus
il se disait la démocratie la démocratie
sociale ne fait pas le travail et il a
vu l'avènement d'hitler en allemagne
donc il regardait l'union soviétique
comme un bastion anti fasciste
l'un des éléments clés selon as
concernant philby
c'est que tout le monde a sous-estimé la
force de son engagement idéologique
l'autre chose qu'il ne faut pas oublier
à son sujet et qu'il avait des capacités
extraordinaires pour la tromperie
c'était un menteur tout à fait brillant
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais l'air
avec le son